on the outskirts of the indonesian
capital
yet another family has lost a relative
to covert 19.
wake up she cries please don't sleep
it's the last time she will ever see her
father
as indonesia struggles through this
surge in covert 19 deaths
there are too many grieving families and
not enough workers to help bury the dead
some communities are now relying on
volunteers
we don't receive any payment we do our
job from the heart
he cleans the bodies and also drives
coffins to the cemetery
the number of deaths is so high here so
this is what we can do to help the
families
they work from morning to night
every day they see more families in
anguish
seeing the conditions of these families
i feel in my heart a need to help them
i think about them even after i get home
this is just one of many covert 19
burial sites in indonesia
at all hours hearses and ambulances
queue up with more bodies to be buried
as doctors are forced to turn away sick
people
more people are dying alone in their
homes and most
never had the chance to be treated in
hospital
as the death toll rises covered 19
burial sites
are overwhelmed and grave diggers have
to work well into the night
to keep up with demand
indonesia's covert 19 fatality rate is
the highest in southeast asia
but experts warn the government's data
doesn't reveal the extent of the crisis
we predict that the real number
of those who died from coffee 19
should be three to five times higher
than the official's number
each day indonesia's cases and debts
rise to record levels
and more families come here to mourn
those they've lost
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta